now could charles moore former editor of
the daily telegraph the
sunday telegraph and indeed the most
important position of all the spectator
could you become the new chairman of the
bbc
he's a vocal critic of the license fee
indeed took his principles all the way
to court in 2010
his appointment could come hand-in-hand
with paul dicker former editor of the
daily mail
taking the lead at ofcom the media
regulator which also
regulates the bbc will have a double
whammy for auntie peep there is it time
for these
kind of changes douglas murray's yes and
this week's spectator
but i'm not joined by claire fox she's
founder of the institute of ideas former
brexit party nep she's a frequent
contributor to bbc shows like the moral
maze i mean claire many people will see
this is just the juries putting their
mates
into nice prestigious positions
actually many people just saw it as them
trolling everybody because the reaction
as that was murray
makes clear was that there was an
absolute meltdown from all sorts of
quarters i think douglas
and quotes one of my favorite ones which
was alan rusbridger
former editor of the uh guardian
who now runs in oxford college basically
complaining about an autocracy and a
government putting their friends in high
places with no sense of irony at all
that he had been appointed to an oxford
college or he'd been the editor of
guardian and he was
just part of a previous era but you know
i i still can't believe that this is
going to
actually happen and it's sort of
enjoyable and good fun
and but i think there's a more serious
and important point here
and you know any government might want
to appoint people
into positions of power and influence
but i think that the greater issue is
that
whilst the conservatives want a massive
majority at the last election it is true
that the institutions in this country
and we've seen this very explicitly in
the last four
years really since brexit
have a particular type of people at
their health
and it's not that they're labor people
they're not it's not a party
point actually a lot of them are tories
there's a lot of tories
who are metropolitan liberals on a
massive number of issues it's not
a kind of party point it's a kind of
world view that sees things in a
particular way
and in that sense i think that there's
been a kind of institutional capture
it's not exactly gramsci in march
through the institutions but it feels
like that and you do feel as though
everybody who runs everything from the
national trust to the british museum to
the
to the bbc so every institution has a
particular way of looking at the world
and therefore are affronted by world
views that don't
uh coincide with their own and i mean
we've just been listening to professor
gupta she's been slightly on the
receiving end of this and he's like
dare one descent on anything and
feel the full wrath of a particular
institutional worldview
so i hope we can shake things
is one way putting bulls into china
shops is not shaking things up
i mean i can understand that the tories
of what labor put its people in
to positions of importance you know tony
blair for
gavin davis is chairman of the bbc craig
dyke as director general
of the bbc both were staunch labor
people greg
donated to the labour party dan davis
was a sort of tony
to to tony crony i get all that they
may want their own people but it's the
kind of people
i'm i mean putting paul dicker into
ofcom
this is the digital age ofcom's big job
now
is regulating uh digital uh um
communications uh paul is an old steam
engine newspaperman
uh with ink in his fingernails
putting charles murray into the bbc
as chairman this is someone that doesn't
even watch any television
uh probably doesn't even know how to
switch one on
or switch one off yeah so i think that's
the plus that's
just vandalism is it not yeah well
that's the danger with it it's um you
know
that all the time there's a feeling that
politics amounts to nothing
more than tit for tat you know even with
something like cancel culture the people
who hate cancer culture decide to cancel
the counsellors
and in this instance it's a bit that's
why i started off saying it's a bit like
trolling you know it's kind of
you've add your people in we'll have our
people in i was simply just trying to
describe
what the issue was and i can understand
the
attempt to shake it up but i don't i
agree with you that just putting place
men or women in you know just shaking it
up by having personnel that will annoy
everyone
isn't really the point and i think that
actually douglas
uh money makes it makes this very clear
that there's there's more profound
cultural questions here on the one hand
it's interesting to see the conservative
government making an attempt
at entering into this cultural arena
which i think is underestimated i think
that
you know this arena of political capture
in the cultural sense is something that
everybody should be concerned about
because it has a
profound impact on the kind of news we
get on the kind of media we have
and the kind of institutions we have but
i would actually
say that what we need to do is not just
put in different people
but actually have a big discussion about
what the attitudes within those
organizations are
i mean and they just respect yourself i
do but it what's
interesting is the impact that the
announcement that you were about to
to be involved in another tv venture has
also
sent shock waves to and when i talk
about shaking things up that's what i
mean
i mean there is a complacency in these
institutions
that there's only one way to view the
world and
look at the shock that people got when
for example in the eu referendum people
didn't go along with things
there is a kind of assumption of
we know best and an outlook that you
dare not challenge
and so i think that what we need is a
shakeup i hope it goes beyond
poor daycare ofcom i'm not making any
comments on that
if that's what it amounts to it's
immature and childish
to be frank it won't make any difference
it's been enjoyable i
i also think it is worth noting that's a
lot of well-known commentators said
things like
if charles moore becomes the head of the
bbc everybody in the bbc will
leave without also noticing that that
indicated a kind of group thing gone mad
you know
what you're admitting is that people all
think with the same way and they don't
want somebody different
in and i i i do think that these things
impact our democracy because there is a
sense in which now people do not feel
that their views are represented in the
media
they do feel as though there is a
one-tone
conversation i think in relation to the
coronavirus issue
there is a you know people about the
stuffing knocked out of them the people
in hartlepool and
the northeast are not rejoicing at the
impact as
as professor gupta has said which is the
economy isn't just some abstract notion
it will destroy the livelihoods of the
people in the northeast
that they've overreacted in this way
that should be discussed without you
being called a cove idiot
you know without being dismissed as some
sort of flat earther who's an
anti-vaxxer
and so i just would appreciate that we
understand that
institutions run by people who have
group think at their core
and only can see things in one
particular way has been incredibly
destructive over trust in institutions
in democracy
and in people in authority and i would
like it to change so i just
i don't mind the odd bit of stirring but
it's not sufficient and a more profound
uh
discussion is required
[Laughter]
[Music]
you